hey guys I'm Ryan what's it on brandy
pressed I'm right right right right no I
mean we're gonna be checking out a
trailer for an indie horror film today
talking about it follows um it's a
horror film flowing though we stay dream
about being old enough going days
this image of myself holding hands is
really cute guy driving won some pretty
road never about going anywhere really
I'm sensitive freedom I guess okay -
wait you're not gonna believe me I need
you to remember what I'm saying think
it's going to follow you we give it to
me right past it to you
whatever you want it's some walking
straight for you all you can do is pass
one in some girls hate if I did did he
really do to you
apparently he used a fake name to rent a
house in the city realize we do you this
is just a game if it kills her it gets
me go straight down the line for every
story
exactly supposed to follow me something
happened
it's not what she thinks okay wait no
it's me
everything's okay you look like someone
you know or could be a stranger in a
crowd whatever helps you get close to
you
interesting right off the bat I do like
the fact of how it's not a creature or
it's something so specific that we know
what it is you like that I really you
know I can't don't like that no I do
like that but I don't like the fact that
you don't really know what it wants all
I know is this thing is gonna [ __ ]
haunt and murder people no no that's my
only concern is you're going to murder
her because it didn't seem really
dangerous the thing yeah there wasn't I
didn't feel that edgy honestly what
might have been doing it for me is the
reviews I was looking at in the trailer
oh maybe probably's is really gullible
they're not like holy [ __ ] that sounds
scary yeah I don't know exactly what era
but it has a little bit of a throwback
vibe to it it does it definitely be kind
of like a Jaws on lamb yeah those house
thing in 70s by - but your friends are
the danger oh it's kind of almost like
poltergeist no but that's what I mean of
why I like it is because like Paranormal
Activity sure you don't see the monster
but it's you know it's a ghost or a dyin
we have ideas of what it could be but we
don't know for sure right nice thing
right now in order to get close to me
and kill me it could be you mm-hmm but
then you're not strangling me or
anything so I guess I should not be
scared and it has a little bit of that
ring thing of you know you have to pass
along to someone else in order to yeah
but how do they pass it along I think
you have sex with them that's what it
seemed like to me too so I don't know
why she's having a hard time you know
it's like she's yeah she's good hi and
you know everyone knows that if a woman
wants it they just get it like that
everyone knows that yeah it's it's
statistics say 98% of women do that
uh-huh yep no I'm reading it wrong
Google never lies I mean I'll be honest
like that when the trailers started
stars laughing a little bit cuz it was
like this looks like every horror film
like it's starting off with a girl in it
some girls swimsuit and then she's
falling in love all you want is love
and it's like even if I didn't know
before watching trailer it was a horror
film I'd still be like well obviously
horrible things are about to happen you
know it's very predictable they're
having sex what I wasn't expecting was
the dude to bounce oh really
yeah in real life I would but in a movie
I'm expect like a third party to kill
them usually someone's like oh there's
something in the woods and then the boy
is an idiot but he's like no I passed
along an STD to you now that's that's
pretty much what he that's that the
reference I was getting from it that
he's passed along an STD yeah she has to
give it to someone else not making fun
of people with STDs I'm just saying like
it seems like a big reference to that
did any film they might be thinking that
you know like I know deep they are yes
people that make any films and always
deep they try to be deeper than most
people they get deeper yeah see I made a
section yeah hahaha like that's what I
mean the guy down says he's like
something's gonna follow you so sorry
but something's coming after you this
thing just seems like it's it's a
haunting more than a killing type of
thing you're right because yeah she
could have died a long time ago right
because like that shot in the hospital
when she was like freaking out like
whoever the actress is I think she looks
like she's doing a really good job she
looks good well she's not only sexy she
looks like she can actually act which is
good yeah when she's like crying in the
hospital bed there's the look like real
fear yeah it didn't look like Hollywood
panting fear yeah yeah yeah the way the
film sort of shot like the
cinematography of it it does have like a
authentic creepy vibe to me about it
because it doesn't look like it's trying
so hard to look dark and menacing but it
looks very stoic like a lot of the shots
are very bland like not bland but
there's there's more sharing like
esoteric yeah very simple that's the
word oh you don't have to be simple you
don't have to use words like exoteric
s so ah there you go huh the quote that
got me was what it said like it's like
an urban legend you've heard your whole
life I do think it has an urban legend
type of vibe to it not the movie
legend you know what I mean yeah an
actual urban legend like Maya Donna or
something
yeah whatever the [ __ ] that is that's a
crying woman she drowns little kids
oh yeah yeah I knew her once horrible
human being
just old bitchin Java tells me and it's
out to try to drown me but I'm the one
that got away oh my god Bloody Mary when
I was a kid I did that I did that [ __ ]
didn't do it I knew Bloody Mary babe
yeah real [ __ ] yep bloody come see that
I al you Pamela
I was like Bambi you don't get I thought
it was really they compared it to cow it
in the woods though it doesn't have a
cabin Martin you know like cabin the
wood comes off direct and then it just
gets batshit crazy like yeah [ __ ] is
high I forgot for a moment that this
film was called it follows I like that
in the trailer I like the Texans I think
horror movie taglines tend to suck
weren't even a tagline it's the title no
but it was it was saying like [ __ ] it
doesn't feel it does you know oh yeah
yeah you like and then it goes if all of
and I was like no that is pretty [ __ ]
scary actually because it does one job
and it's gonna fulfill it's like a shark
nose on water jaws on water my dad
jaws on and I was like why isn't brandy
going yeah then I realized why let you
go sound like an idiot huh there's a
very exoteric s so s oh when in room I
thought that one guy kind of looked like
Joshua Jackson I thought it was Joshua
Jackson but he's obviously way younger
but I think Joshua Jackson's one of
those people who like looks young yeah
anyway guys yeah thanks to whomever
recommended that trailer if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects and brandy has a channel
too and she's doing a lot of independent
movie reviews you should really check
you're looking at me like are you
promoting your channel right oh you
should check out her independent reviews
and see you come to the real rejects for
the bigger movies and the occasional
small movies and then you know you go to
her very small movies for the movies
no one knows or the ones that they do
know but didn't necessarily watch or we
don't even want to watch but I like
they're good yeah I think so well not
all of them some of them I watching
they're real crappy Hey
okay no there's not gonna make a poop
joke he really wants to I really want to
go I really want to poop it's poking out
the alley oop is rubbed